ليله صوت الارض ليله فنيه هي الاضخم تك
تكرم علما من اعلام الفن العربي وعمودا من
اعمده الاغنيه السعوديه وعلى الرغم من
مرور 22 عاما على رحيله الا ان صوت طلال
مداح ما زال عالقا في الذاكره بالفعل نجوم
العرب اجتمعوا في تظاهر فنيه سعوديه
خليجيه عربيه كبرى تكريما لصوت مؤرخ
الاغنيه السعوديه طلال مداح كان محور ليلى
ليست ككل الليالي على مسرح محمد عبده
وايضا بمبادره من هيئه الترفيه في
السعوديه نعود الان الى تلك الليله التي
حضرها فريق صباح العربيه نتابع
[موسيقى]
امام ثلاثه الاف مستمع
توفي وهو يغني على مسرح المفتاح في مدينه
ابها بالسعوديه
فارق صاحب الحنجره الذهبيه الحياه في لحظه
من المستحيل ان تسقط من ذاكره محبيه
وعشاقه طلال بن عبد الشيخ بن احمد بن جعفر
الجابري احب العزف والغناء منذ طفولته
وكان يغني في الحفلات المدرسيه وكان والده
عاشقا للعزف على التيه السمسميه والمدروف
التي تشبه الناي
شاءت الاقدار ان يتعرف على عبد الرحمن
خندنه واجتمع الاثنان على حب الموسيقى
والغناء حيث كان عبد الرحمن عاشقا للعزف
على اله العود ومنه تعلم طلال مداح العزف
على اله العود وتاثر بافكاره الموسيقيه
وبعد مسلسل طويل من المخاوف والتردد قرر
الطلح اول اغنياته وهي وردك يا زارع الورد
ونجحت الاغنيه داخل السعوديه قدم طلال
مداح عبر مسيرته الفنيه 85 البوما وكان
يجيد الغناء
بثمان لهجات عربيه كما اهلته موهبته
الرائعه للتعاون مع عدد كبير من الملحنين
والشعراء في العالم العربي
ومنحه النقاد العديد من الالقاب مثل صوت
الارض صاحب الحنجره الذهبيه وفارس الاغنيه
السعوديه
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا مشاهدينا نتواجد في هذه الليله
التاريخيه والتي اطلقت عليها هيئه ترفيه
للصوت الارض باجتماع نجوم الفن حيث يضم
هذا الحفل اكثر من 40 فنان وذلك تكريما
للراحه طلال مداح صباح العربيه متواجده
اليوم لتنقل لكم تفاصيل هذه الليله
حنين
[موسيقى]
بدات بوابات المسرح في استقبال الجمهور
الذي بدا في التوافد على المنطقه مبكرا
للمشاركه في المحفل الاستثنائي الذي
يتابعه العالم عبر اكثر من عشرات الشاشات
التابعه لمجموعه من القنوات المحليه
والدوليه
استمتعوا اليوم واسمعوا الفن على اصوله من
اساتذه الفن في ارض الفن
[موسيقى]
كتبته
وعلى لون السماء الهادي على الوادي على
موتي وميلاقي
لصوت الارض الله يغفر له رجل عزيز على
قلبي وحبيبي
وتربطني في علاقه شخصيه فانا سعدت
بهالمشاركه والله
فرحه الناس بها وبهجتها كذا
انا شعوري يفوق هذا هذا الفرح الفرح الان
فخوره بهالجمع الفنيه الر
ائعه اللي انا بعتبرها
تضاف الى الفن اكيد لانه ما بعتقد صار شيء
من هالنوع قبل بالفن العربي طبعا شعوري
شعور لا يوصف
فنان راحل وفنان له قيمه كبيره
واحنا في الطفولتنا عشنا معاه في اغانيه
وفي شبابنا كل في كل اللحظات الجميله
تشريف وواجب وفخور اني متواجد اليوم في
ليله عظيمه ليله التكريم الراحل طلب
المداح اللي عاش معانا مع ذكرياتنا ومع
اغانيهم مع كل كل مشاعرنا في حياتنا
والاجيال قعده وفن اصيل تربينا عليه
وتعلمنا منك
[موسيقى]
تاريخيه عاشتها الرياض اجتمع فيها فنانو
العرب تكريما للمرحوم الفنان طلال مداح ان
شاء الله
تصير ليله من الف ليله وتصير في التاريخ
انتم ابناء فنان عظيم من حقكم انكم ترفعون
راسكم في بلدكم اليوم في تكريم ابوكم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لصباح العربيه محمد خالد الرياض
من الرياض نورنا ابن الفنان طلال مداح عبد
الله طلال مداح عبد الله يسعد صباحك اهلا
بك شكرا على تواجدكم معنا في صباح العربيه
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
يا اهلا وسهلا يا اهلا وسهلا فيكم طيب
يعني
القلب ما يقال عنها انها ليله تاريخيه
ملحميه بحضور
اكبر ليله كانت بصوت الارض يعني الراحل
طلال مداح اولا كيف كان شعوركم وانتم
تشاهدون ليله تكريم الوالد
اولا انا ودي اني اقدم شكري والجزيل
مقام مولاي خادم الحرمين الشريفين ولي
عهده على
الاهتمام
بالفن في المملكه
مركز في
جهود المستشار
معالي الشيخ تركي
بالامس كانت ليله تاريخيه كانت ليله فريده
من نوعها
عاشها الطلاليين بكل تفاصيلها
[موسيقى]
بوثقه من اجمل الاصوات العربيه
كانت متواجده معانا في الحفل
واعتقد انها حتكون ليله تخلد
تخلت التاريخيه
استاذ عبد الله
يعني فعلا كانت ليله ساحره وفوق الخيال
بكل المقاييس سيد عبد الله في العاده لكل
فنان جمهوره لكن بالنسبه للراحل طلال مداح
لا يختلف عليه اثنان اما من السعوديين او
حتى من الفنانين العرب ومن الجمهور العرب
بالتالي عفويه وبساطه طلال كانسان كيف
انعكست على فنه وعلى جوده حفلاته
خلينا نقول انه تميز
الوالد رحمه الله عليه كان في بساطه وكان
في
عفويته في تواضعه
فكان قريب
لجمهوره قريب
للشخص العادي اللي اللي المستمع
فهذه اثرت تاثير كثير على
خلينا نقول جمهور في العالم سواء في
العالم العربي او في
عندنا خصوصا يعني
ما اعتقد انه
حنلقى شخص مثلا
ما يحب او يكره
طلال رحمه الله عليه
اما انه يحبوا لشخصه او يحبوا لفنه او
يحبوا لجزئيه ما في في شخصيته
وهذا
خلينا نقول ان هي نعمه من نعم الله عليه
انه يكون عنده هذا هذا القبول عند
المجتمع وعند الجمهور
طيب السيد عبد الله يعني على رغم مروه 22
عاما على رحيل الفنان الكبير طلال مداح
يعني لا تزال اغاني مخلده عربيا والسعوديا
ما هي المعايير التي جعلته فنانا يخلد
الاغنيه السعوديه
[موسيقى]
نقدر نقول انه
العوامل المحيطه به سواء ببدايات او حتى
في ظهور الفني
تعامله مع زي ما قلنا مع الجمهور مع من
حوله ساهم كثير في هذا الشيء يعني بساطته
في حد ذاته
[موسيقى]
بتساهم انه
تكون انت اقرب للمستمعه
اللي هو خلينا نقول العادي المستمر
الطبيعي
[موسيقى]
طلال في حد ذاته يعني كوالدي من الصعب اني
انا اتكلم عنه
على قولهم
بالمديح لانه مهما كان فهو والدي يعني
فاكيد حمده لكن تميزه
في نظر جمهوره
هو اكبر تميز جمهور وكان يشوفوا يشوفوا
حاجه فريده حاجه
نادره
ويمكن هذا اللي خلى اللي هو
تعامل الجمهور معه يكون بشكل حميمي اكثر
من انه مجرد انه اغنيه اسمعها او فنان
اسمعوا او كذا طيب يا استاذ عبد الله شو
السر اليوم انه رغم تعاقب الاجيال ونتحدث
من ثوره الاغنيه السعوديه في السبعينات
وفي الثمانينات وحتى قبل وفاه الراحل طلال
مداح يعني في فتره التسعينات الى انه ما
زالت اغنيه طلال مداح وما زال الفن
الطلالي حاضر حتى مع الاجيال الجديده ما
السر
والله حقيقه
انا
ودي اني انا اعرف السر هذا لانه
الجماهيريه
خلينا نقول المتعاقبه
المتزايده حتى يعني احنا بنلاحظ انه في
خلينا نقول شعبيه اكبر من من ما سبق
بحيث انه
انت عارفها اغلبيه الفنانين اللي هم خلينا
نقول الجيل السابق الجيل القديم
اغلبيه
مستمعينهم يكونوا عاده من فئه عمريه معينه
يعني اللي هم كبار السن وحاجه زي كذا
لكن بنتفاجا انه المستمعين الوالد رحمه
الله عليه
شباب صغار صغار في السن يعني في العشرينات
وفي
اقل واكبر يعني وهذا هذا حقيقه احنا
بنشوفه انها هي
[موسيقى]
بلاش نقول غريبه
ولكن فريده من نوعها يعني تعامل جمهوره
معاه غريب جدا
جمهور بيزداد يوميا بيزداد
كلما مرت مثلا فتره او مرت سنه او مرت هذه
بيزيدوا لله الحمد يعني وهذا من فضل ربي
عليه
[موسيقى]
احنا بنشكرك جزيل الشكر ومنشكرك لوجودك
معنا شكرا لكم من الرياض ابن الفنان طلال
مداح عبد الله طلال مداح شكرا